[Musik]
jawoh mein Name ist Hauptmann Mannschaf
Nikola ich bin leheroffizier an der
Theresianischen militärkademie wir
befinden uns jetzt hier gerade an der
flugfeldkaserne in wienerneustadt hier
findet gerade eine sogenannte statische
waffenschaustatt wir befinden uns hier
mit der kaderanwärter Ausbildung 1 in
der Stärke von ungefähr 230 Personen
diese kaderanwärter sind eben wie der
Name schon sagt das das zukünftige Kader
des Bundesheeres berufsunteroffiziers
und
berufsoffiziersanwärter die Kameraden
die Damen und Herren sind hier um sich
das Gerät um sich die Systeme des
Bundesheeres anzusehen diese all diese
Waffensysteme die Gerätschaften die man
hier sieht sind hier aufgestellt weil
eben heute im Anschluss im Nachmittag
die Parade im Zuge der Ausmusterung 2023
stattfindet also ich B V der
Militärmusik und bin gerade auf der
keranwert Ausbildung 1 und schau wir da
wo sie quasi noch machen möcht
Militärmusik war klasse Zeit aber war
heute meine Zukunft wird hoffentlich was
nachpannendes bringen bin ich da dassmer
heutechau mir interessiert mil
interessiert Kommando mir interessiert
Pilot mir interessieren die Pioniere ja
mal schauen wo es mich hier Verschlag
also ich habe bei der Stellung einen
coolen Vortrag gehört über die
Möglichkeiten beim bundesher das wurd
echt super aufgezeigt über die
offiziersaufbahn über die
Unteroffizierslaufbahn und mich hat
generell interessiert weil ich wollte
sowas machen schon in der Richtung ich
dachte entweder bundesweher Polizei
sowas wollte ich schon immer machen und
ja jetzt bin ich beim bundesr über seit
einen Monat über einen Monat schon dabei
und eigentlich es ist sehr cool es ist
natürlich auch sehr strengend psychisch
als auch physisch aber es macht doch
immer Spaß und ich glaube es wird auch
weiterhin Spaß machen und ich freue mich
schon auf die Cup 2
und ich würd es jeden empfehlen man kann
es gerne probieren warum nicht macht s
eigenungstest man kann sich super darauf
vorbereiten alles steht im Internet und
ich würde mich freuen wenn ich in
einehalb Jahre dann als Unteroffizier
ausmuster also ich bin jetzt beim
bundesher weil ich mir immer schon
gedacht habe ich würde gerne eigentlich
zum bundsag Gehen habe ich mir mit 12
das erste mal gedacht und dann die
nächsten Jahre bisschen aus den Augen
verloren aber dann mit S mir wieder
gedacht ich will es wirklich durchziehen
und es hat mich nichts daran gehindert
das durchzuziehen ich habe mir gedacht
das kann eigentlich nichts passieren
außer dass ich wieder aufhören will und
ich will hauptsächlich wegen weil ich
sehr gerne in der Natur bin und
natürlich wegen der Kameradschaft und
außerdem auch weil ich sehr gerne einen
Beruf mit Sport haben wollte wo ich sehr
sportlich aktiv bin und das immer mit
meinem Beruf verbunden habe das war mir
sehr wichtig und deswegen habe ich mir
gedacht beim bundeser bin ich da sehr
gut aufgehoben und probiere das aus der
Jahrgang general Theodor Körner mustert
an diesem Wochenende aus und hier bieten
wir der keranwerter Ausbildung 1 die
Möglichkeit eben teilzunehmen um das
Ganze aus erster Hand zu sehen um mir
wirklich die Ausmusterung und das Ziel
des
des jungen Offiziers quasi selber zu
schmecken und wahrzunehmen die
karanwerter sind seit gestern hier
haben sich gestern eben die die
ausmusterungsfeierlichkeiten angesehen
wurden eingewiesen in die Ausbildung in
die Offiziersausbildung in die zwei
Studiengänge die wir haben und heute
haben sie eben die Möglichkeit sich eben
vor Ort die Gerätschaften anzusehen und
alles auch wirklich anzugreifen Fragen
zu stellen und sich ein Bild davon zu
machen wie der Offiziersberuf aussieht
wie der unteroffiziersberuf aussieht
welche Systeme wir haben was sie haben
werden um es dann in weiterer Folge auch
zu führen und zu verwalten
um hier wirklich auch einen einen
vertieften Einblick zu geben wir machen
das in dieser Form noch nicht seit
langem das ist ein ein ein recht neues
Vorhaben so wie wir das heute haben und
ich denke es ist auf jeden Fall eine
spannende Sache dass man als als
zukünftiger Kaders sooldat des
Bundesheeres hier die ersten Eindrücke
sammelt ähm Fragen beantwortet bekommt
und sich auf den ja zukünftigen ber
Beruf freuen
[Musik]
darf